I can't believe
that kid that was harming
themselves
would end up sitting here.
I've come so far.
For the first time,
I'm seeing that
there's an abundance of
opportunity.
I wish I wouldn't
have blamed myself so much
for the way I felt
and for the self-harm,
because that's made it harder.
All I actually needed
to do was to be brave enough
to step out of myself.
Self-harm behaviours
are warning signs
that something is not right.
There's great optimism
for people making
a recovery that's good
and that lasts.
I first sort of
started to self-harm
when I was about 16.
It was a lack of confidence
and sort of feeling like
I didn't fit in anywhere,
and I just had all this
frustration about
my identity, who I was.
My mum was just worried
about me constantly.
I was not really
talking to anyone about it,
just assuming this was normal
and everyone felt like that.
I experienced self-harm
related to my anger especially.
From a young age I kind of
learned that anger was
a scary thing or a thing that I
shouldn't allow myself to feel.
I experienced trauma
that I blacked out,
that I couldn't access
for years.
I didn't really know what
I was doing
or have a plan,
or purpose, even.
But I was getting desperate.
Self-harm is a behaviour,
and it's a form of
communication.
Self-harm expresses
emotional pain
through a transformation
into physical pain.
There are a few statistics
in relation to self-harm.
One in six children and
young people aged 16 years
in England had a problem
with mental illness in 2021.
That would
translate to something like
five children in every
classroom of 30.
You can self-harm
in multiple ways.
It doesn't always have to be
through the standard ways
that we know.
Self-harming relationships,
substance misuse -
so there's a variety of
different ways
in which people do it.
I self-harmed
on and off with cutting,
then I developed
an eating disorder.
I just became
very secretive
and then it sort of turned into
more neglecting myself.
I'd been out drinking
and I just didn't stop.
I noticed that
a lot of my anger
was directed at myself,
whether it was like
pinching myself
or biting the inside of
my cheek, things like that.
A lot of my bingeing would
happen when I was angry
or upset and didn't feel like
I was being listened to.
In the very traditional
gender-based ways,
often males
will tend to self-harm
in quite violent ways,
so getting into a fight,
sometimes, or they put
their fist through a glass.
We're learning a lot more about
the experience of trauma.
There's a kind of
capital-T trauma,
but there's also
small-T trauma.
All those small wounds
that we all have
from adverse life experiences
where perhaps we felt
we haven't been seen or known.
So it's not that
something happened -
maybe something didn't happen.
People know that
it's hard being a teenager.
It just wasn't that.
My parents wanted to help,
but they didn't know how,
so I hid it better. I didn't
want to ask for help
because I didn't want to seem
like I was attention-seeking,
or belittled, or made fun of.
You want to be seen,
but you don't want attention
for the self-harm.
When people
say that self-harm
is attention-seeking is to
see it as attention-needing.
Because self-harm is
a form of communication,
in order to move forward,
you need to find an alternative
form of communication,
convert it into any other
outward form of communication
rather than making it implode,
making the pain
implode back on you.
Something
I'm doing to work towards
living a better life
is therapy.
I still withhold a lot
of myself from other people,
but I definitely get to
talk to myself
through the art that I do.
My anger is a wave
that can come and go.
Being angry doesn't make me
an angry person.
I got a journal out
and just started writing.
I tend to share
a lot of my poetry
or anything I've written
with my mum.
Through running
my Instagram account
and working in the mental
health industry, I think
it's shown how much helping
other people has helped myself.
Walking
is a great tool for me.
Walking allows me to
process things in my mind.
I do lots of
different things.
I've had to plan my life
in a way that
I feel good
and I don't relapse.
It's important to get your
feelings out in whatever way.
Creative projects
are really good in order to
learn how to verbalise things
and understand what's going on.
Coming together
with a group of people
that were like myself,
sharing words
and experiences,
feels really comforting.
Expressing myself
in a creative way
using my own words
I never thought would be
possible for someone like me.
One thing I've
learnt over the last year or so
is that it just takes a few
moments of bravery
to get the support
that you need.
You don't need to feel
that you deserve it,
you just need to know
you need it.
It's not always
going to be perfect,
but just do your best.
No matter what you do,
people are there
to support you.
We definitely need to be open
for people to
tell us what they need.
Society just needs to be
a lot more person-centred
and trauma-informed.
Being trauma-aware,
we have responsibility
with the young people to relate
to them where they are.
Having some compassion
that somebody may have
experienced some trauma
is helpful.
It's really important
to see this
as a period of time
in your life which you marked
as being distressing,
and to be able to see that
as a phase that you have now
moved from, and to be proud
of having got through it.
You can do it.
I thought that was it.
Whatever I was feeling,
wherever I was then
was going to be forever.
And it wasn't.
It hasn't been easy
every step of the way,
growing up, or as an adult,
but it is not the same.
Things change, and they get
better, and, er...
...come and go.
(MUSIC PLAYING)